[Music]
in a few moments you're gonna lose
consciousness
i'm gonna count down from three
and two
and one
[Music]
swim song is an amazing love story about
two people who adore each other but one
of them cameron is dying
cameron finds out about a technology to
create a perfect duplicate of himself
and leave this duplicate behind without
his family knowing
i know you're going through
the second you tell your wife your
opportunity to do this is gone
ethically morally you understand why
this would be a very difficult decision
you're gonna be good man none like this
all those memories that mine and my
wife's they're my sons
i'm sorry doctor
i can't do this
the film is all about the human elements
the love story the sacrifice
everybody will think what would i do in
a situation like that would i love
someone enough to die on my own so that
they would be spared the pain of my loss
i can't stop picturing her getting the
news
having to tell court
it's about what human relationships are
and how far someone will go for love
i love you man i love you too dad
do i allow someone to take over my life
love my child and my wife that is
technically me but it's not me you just
can't bear to see this actually work
that's the real problem because you're
not me you are not me
it's hard to be left behind
[Music]
you